hi my name is Patrick Thompson I work at
github on the semantic code team our
goal as a team is to help developers
understand write improve and maintain
their source code and as part of that
mission we write tools to consume and
analyze the corpus of code on github and
that's something that's very much easier
said than done because github hosts
billions upon billions of lines of code
and building tools that are capable of
handling that volume of data that's not
easy I'm here to talk about a library
originally written by my friend and
teammate Rob Rick's that we use to build
these tools it's called fused effects
and it's written in the functional
programming language Haskell quick poll
here how many of you know Haskell even
like a little bit what so many on among
my people how many use Haskell or have
you use Haskell for work for dogs yeah
this library is called fused effects and
from an application level view of fused
effects is a library atop which you
build programs it's provides the basic
building blocks that when composed
together provide you the programmer a
sufficiently expressive vocabulary to
fit your need but we can take a
different view perhaps a more formal and
precise perspective and so speaking
technically it's an effect system one
that provides higher-order scope defects
and handlers for those effects that
display fusion properties if this seems
like jargon it's because it is will
cover some in some detail exactly what
that means later and from a systems view
the nuts and bolts perspective it's a
real-world production quality library
designed for applications that don't
want to sacrifice performance for
expressivity semantics code team has
built several applications with the used
effects of power powering real-world
github features and in our experience
they've performed really admirably I'm
here to talk about how we traditionally
build Haskell programs and why we own
the semantic code team found that
tradition limiting also some examples of
how fused effects can overcome those
limitations and I'll talk about the
values that create and trade-offs that
have guided its evolution as well as the
aspects of its design that make it
suitable for real-world Haskell
development but first let's
step back fundamentally fuse effects is
an answer to a question and it's this
question how do we build programs in
Haskell when I sit down to write a
Haskell program having identified the
behavior I need to implement how do i
express that behavior in code that is
how do I translate my intent to
operation this capable of being
understood by my fellow humans and by a
computing device and if that question
seems abstract and wide-ranging it's
good because it definitely is the first
step in getting a handle on the scope of
a question like this is to define a
couple of terms I want to be precise in
my speech so let's start at the basics
my boy leave it consign describe the
world as all that is the case I hope
that's not too controversial and Edgar
Dykstra our fifty or so years later had
a nice and formal definition of
computers or at least formal enough for
our purposes that as describing them as
mechanical equipment that can change the
world
we run computations to cause these
changes and in doing so these
computations may have access to their
environment the environment here
represents not just the state of the
world as it is the set of all possible
worlds that have occurred in the past so
not just than now but also everything
leading up to the now when we tell a
computer to do something and in doing so
it depends upon or changes that
environment we call that an effect or a
side effect
the adjective over here form here is
effect 'full interesting programs
produce effects a program that doesn't
produce any effects is either a no op or
it's a theorem prover I guess in all
other cases we write a program and run a
program so that it produces a change in
the world around us
these are all examples of effects an
input and output is really the
archetypal one printing a value to the
console or to the screen or somewhere
changes the operating system's
environment your OS makes a system call
and it fills up a buffer somewhere and
it discharges that to your rendering
advice and poof you've got a change in
the world around you and another effect
is the presence of mutable variables we
can destructively assign to a mutable
variable and effect
all subsequent computations that query
is that's a good and useful property of
a system to have mutable variables are
very important for so many tasks but it
means that if my code relies on mutable
variables it relies on the current
environment and all environments that
have preceded it that involved such
assignments to mutable variables every
common programming language provides you
the programmer with at least some of
these effects that I listed up there and
usually these effects are pervasive or
Universal if I'm writing some code in
Python for example any line of code can
throw an exception or making a network
call or terminate the program early so
the ability to invoke these effects is
woken woven into the fabric of Python
itself the thing that makes Haskell
different from most other programming
language is that it uses types to track
effects Haskell boasts a feature called
a type system which is a language that
runs before my code runs and it checks
my code to ensure to some degree but the
computations I've described are
semantically valid and the fact that
Haskell makes its effects explicit means
that before we write line one of a
Haskell code base we have to sit down
and think and we confront this
immediately if you don't read Haskell
this is a type signature of a
computation name domain it specifies
that main is an IO effect that returns
no result that's those little double
parentheses right there and every
Haskell program starts here when I
execute a program written in Haskell the
GHC runtime system finds the function
called main runs it and by marking main
as being an input and output effect
we're saying that running a Haskell
program changes something about the
world if we didn't need to cause that
effect we wouldn't be running the
program in the first place I like this
because it's expressing using the type
system of what Dijkstra pointed out
which is that we run programs for their
effects on the computer and by extension
on the world at large we can compose
functions that return IO effects and we
can build simple programs out of them
and philosophically we can view
functions that use this IO effect when
expressed in Haskell as a mini language
or interacting with the computers and
putting output capabilities and many of
you knew know what these languages are
called they're called domain-specific
since they concentrate on expressing a
single problem domain dsls are an answer
at least a partial answer to the
question I posed at the beginning of
this talk in Haskell we build programs
by identifying the domain-specific
languages we need and writing code in
those languages
indeed I go so far as to call Haskell a
DSL oriented programming language DSL x'
aren't everyone's cup of tea all the
time but I like them because they make
what I think is a pretty radical
statement which is that people are more
important than computers if I have to
solve a problem without being able to
express myself in a way that's natural
in a way that fits the language of my
problem domain I'm saying that a
computer's needs are more important than
my own and I don't like that I place
human needs above the values above the
needs of computers and that leads us to
another question if there doesn't
already exist a DSL sufficient to
express my code in a language of its
problem domain what am I to do how do I
build the DSL or compose existing ones
to get something I can work with well we
do that with data structures despite
Haskell being a functional programming
language it's really big on data
structures and most notably data
structures that compose - that conform
to a certain interface and that's the
dreaded M word monads I got seven whole
minutes into this presentation without
mentioning monads I think that's a world
record the details of what a monad is
and if the laws they abide by and
yadda-yadda yeah that's not important to
the task at hand I promise what's
important to understand about monads is
that they're a unified interface for a
great many effects library authors
provide data structures that conform to
the monad interface and we use this
interface with the familiar syntax I
showed you this code already monads
allow us known as allow us using the do
notation and the bind arrow operation to
write imperative code in a functional
setting but this index generalizes
beyond just IO here's some code that
computes Pythagorean triples with
less than 10 and in this context that
left arrow there means choose choose an
element but in the length in the list of
0 through 10 and we can generalize it
even further to something like the Zelda
library which uses the query monad to
express database operations that are
translated into sequel so the upshot of
this is that Haskell libraries provide
data structures that are monads and we
use these monads to express effects
rather than than being woven into the
func and into the fabric of a language
the natural next question is great if
monads represent effects and we build
dsls by composing effects we clearly
need to compose monads and how do we do
that and the answer is you don't or at
least not generally certain monads
compose trivially but there exists no
general method to just pluck to
arbitrary monads from the ether and
combine them in such a way that they're
that they always type check and they're
their invariants are always respected
and from pretty much the get-go this was
recognized as a really pressing problem
in the Haskell community because if
monads resist composition then it makes
it hard for us to express our programs
compositionally and if that's hard then
kind of what's the point of writing in
Haskell anyway so laying hoodak and
Jones took a swing at this particular
issue and the method they came up with
monad transformers stuck
each munna transformer is a data type
that surrounds and transforms another
monad inside I like to think of it as
sort of a jawbreaker or whatever large
hard candy you may have grown up with
and that there's an element at the
centre here it's IO and that we're
building in this example a simple monad
that's capable of responding to an HTTP
request and some sort of web framework
so we start with IO at the center
because we'll probably need to call out
to the operating systems at some point
we add the writer monad on top of it
which gives us login capabilities we add
the reader monad a top of it which gives
us access to the immutable current HTTP
request and then we add the error monad
which lets us terminate early with some
with you know some eight four oh four or
five hundred or whatever the one four
I'm a teapot is and it seems like at
this point we've reached the end of the
line of questioning that I posed we
construct programs by writing dsls
we write dsls by composing effects and
we compose effects by composing Mona
transformers and this is indeed a
strategy that works it's become the
de-facto approach for building
composable and reusable code in Haskell
the two libraries that provide this
functionality are MDL and transformers
transformers provides the concrete
implementation of these data types these
monad transformers and MDL provides an
abstract interface to these capabilities
so that you can write abstractly rather
than pinning your code to the definition
of some such monad transformer stack I'm
going to refer to both of these under
the umbrella name MDL since MDL +
transformers is a little bit of a
mouthful NTL and transformers together
form a library providing the tools to
express and compose effects and we call
this an effect system an effect system
provides us with compositional data
structures powerful enough to express
interesting effects and a set of
interfaces that it lets us abstract away
their underlying details and this
provides us a platform for building
Haskel apps both small and large and as
it happens I work on a large Haskell app
with these lovely people and one of them
in the back what's up - this year the
semantic code team we open sourced our
library for a program analysis it's
called semantic and you can go check it
out it powers really cool features at
github semantic lets you parse analyze
compare and diff and interpret source
code across many different languages we
currently support Python Ruby typescript
PHP javascript and go and I'm probably
forgetting one because there are a lot
of languages with the consistent
interface to all these languages and as
much as I'd like to spend the next
half-hour so talking about semantics
this is not to talk about semantics but
that will happen one day I promise stay
tuned at its heart though semantics is
an implementation
of ideas from a really wonderful paper
out of UMD called abstracting
definitional interpreters this paper
outlines really beautiful methodology
for building interpreters for
programming languages these interpreters
can be concrete in that they execute the
programs they're fed directly like the
interpreter is for JavaScript and Ruby
and Python that we all know where you
stick in a program and you get a result
or they can be abstract an abstract
interpreter computes a program
properties of a program without actually
executing it and this is really useful
for program analysis at a company like
github because we want to be able to
analyze your code without running it and
what's great about abstracting
definitional interpreters is that it
provides a recipe to start with a simple
concrete interpreter and then by
changing the effects this interpreter it
can access making it more powerful until
it becomes an abstract interpreter and
here's a few visual representation of
the first view interpreters that Adi
defines start with a simplest one which
has access to an environment and a heap
we add some logging and we get a 1 with
tracing when we add some and then when
we add some non-determinism we get an
abstract interpreter and when we add
some a state that allows us to cache
previous results we get an abstract
interpreter with caching and if we have
an abstract interpreter with caching
then we're like three cars of the way to
an analysis like a type checker or a
dependency graph analyzer or a scope
checker
for your favorite programming languages
but this paper in particular poses a
problem when we try to express it in
haskell implementing the algorithm that
adi describes with the techniques that
MTL gives you is hard it's possible yes
but it requires that you bend over
backwards to express yourself and you
could argue that this is just an
implementation detail but I think
there's a little bit more to it than
that I think it's a collision of values
Adi is about compositionality the
essence of the paper is about building
interpreters and augmenting their
capabilities by changing the monads and
the effects that power them and so it as
such it places a really high value on
expressiveness and compositionality and
though the MPL authors valued those
things very much
MTL values other things as well and
things that are
at odds with the code style that adi
encourages brian Cantrell who is a great
dude a great prevent a great presenter
former CTO of joint has a wonderful
presentation at node summit in 2017
called platform as a reflection of
values I really recommend seeking it out
and watching it because it provides a
bride's media metrics not a perfect
metric but a metric for something that I
didn't have before that I didn't
necessarily consider if you find
yourself as at of technical crossroads
deciding between libraries or operating
systems or some such platform for
thought and you enumerate the things
that you value in whatever situation you
find yourself and you enumerate the
things that your platform values you
compare these enumerations you have a
framework for endless for understanding
how well this platform will work for
your given situation how many values do
you share the more values you share them
as likely or it is that you're going to
have a good time both writing and
deploying and maintaining all of this so
here's a list of values that the fused
of X team keeps in mind some of these
are generalizable to any software
library some of them are specific to
haskell libraries like the type
inference that you have there and some
of these most importantly are at odds
with each other
we know that sometimes the most elegant
solution is not the most performance
solution and not the most debuggable
solutions so the development of a
library and indeed the development of
any engineering process is identifying
the values that to which you need to
cleave and identifying the values that
you may have to give up in exchange the
authors of MTL placed a really high
value on performance code written with
the abstractions that mdl and
transformers provide usually runs
compare ibly quickly to that written
without any such abstractions and it's
also pretty approachable overall and
monad transformers are not a huge leap
beyond regular monads and I think part
of the journey of learning Haskell is
expressing these transformers yourself
and NCL also values type inference
greatly GH so you can look at an MTL
application and figure out pretty much
exactly what type each part should have
without us the program
as programmers having to annotate at
every step of the way and there's some
things that they compromised on
concision is one of them and the ntl
code can be very concise in the simple
case but more advanced uses of ntl
require what can be a tremendous amount
of boilerplate code due to what's called
the n squares N squared instances
problem and it also made compromises of
expressiveness in the name of type
inference when MTL first emerged GHC
didn't have the subtle tools that we
have now like the type applications
extension that it has today to give the
compiler hints as to what types such and
such an expression should have and as
such it made choices that make it easy
for a simpler compiler to infer the type
of a program but these choices
ultimately limit our expressive
capabilities and here's an example of
this we can see it in one such interface
the this interface monad reader allows
us to read an immutable context from a
context the Esso that means that the ask
method in some monad M implementing
monad reader for a type c DX returns
that c d x value wrapped up in an M if
we bring this back to our example of an
HTTP server we'd say that the HTTP monad
would declare an instance for monad
readers such that it returned a value of
type HTTP request and that means that
ask has a fixed meaning inside this hgp
monad this arrow here that little right
arrow is what establishes that property
that fixed meaning property it's called
the functional dependency and what it
states is here is that each M if it
implements this interface maps to a
unique type C DX
so a monad doesn't have to implement the
monad reader interface at all but if it
does so then it can only do so once we
can't ask for different types of things
and that would preclude code like this
this is perfectly valid code like I want
to ask for the server configuration as
well as the current HTTP request
but this would refuse to compile now
often we can work around this by hey
we've two components just bundle them
together in some sort of data type and
it will it will work out I promise
but that's not always the case let's
take a look at some of the interpreters
that I showed you earlier
each of these three interpreters has
there come their components are unique
specifically we don't have more than one
state component in each of these but
this one is a little different we have
two state types here one represents the
liveness for a dead code analysis and
one represents the heap and this means
we couldn't use the Monad reader
interface to access each of these
individually we'd have to aggregate them
into some top-level container type and
that's I mean that's fine but we have to
jump through a few hoops to do that and
we lose separation of concerns by
bundling up these two data types that
don't necessarily relate to each other
directly and this one it's even more
pernicious it's made much trickier by
the ordering of effects note the
presence of the non-determinism effect
and because it lies because the cache
lies below it the effects of every
non-deterministic computation will be
made visible in that cache however
because the heap lies above it only the
branches that succeed will make their
effects visible in the heap and this
means that we can't bundle these two
these this cache and this heap together
in the same data type because the their
access patterns are interpreted
differently based on their position in
the stack of the effects tying them
together would restrict them to a single
interpretation and this that would
preclude this composition from working
correctly
now it's possible to work around this
with MTL but it takes a lot of code and
it really it's frustrating it sucks and
so on the semantics team we turned our
eyes from Transformers and MTL and we
turned our eyes to the world of
algebraic effects well cover exactly
what an algebraic effects system is
later on but the important thing to know
for now is that algebraic effects
represent effects as data types directly
as we run code written with algebraic
effects our code makes requests to what
are called handlers and they send these
data types to handler this handler will
be listening for a data type to come
down the
it will compute and interpret that data
type in whatever manner is pleasing it's
in the current context and then it will
provide results back to the caller
so whereas MTL is modeled around fixed
interpretations algebraic effect systems
are more dynamic a single interpreting
--gel effect can be interpreted by many
different handlers depending on what
context you're in and if this is
sounding like design patterns from
object orientation observers and
dependency injection and yadda-yadda
yeah yeah you're on the right track this
is not a new idea
by any stretch of the imagination it
started in 2001 with flocking and powers
papers where they formally proved that
algebraic effect representation is
equivalent in power to monad and so the
alts saw a good bit of work on the
theoretical backing but then in 2013 the
rubber really kind of hit the road when
Olay Kiselyov started using them in
Haskell so semantics to my knowledge is
the largest open source Haskell code
base using algebraic effects may be the
largest code base period using algebraic
effects production traffic on github.com
flows through semantics it specifically
powers the jump to definition and find
all references feature that are
currently in beta and that hopefully
I've you've gotten a chance if you use
github to use and play with and it's
been a really good fit for us we adopted
it kind of from day one we had in 2016
we forked and started working on our own
algebraic effects system which was based
off the work of allele dev who based her
work off of
Oleg's original paper big shout out to
both of them and it worked we were able
to work around the problems inherent to
the MDL interface and our our core
implementation of the abstracting
definitional interpreters paper was
elegant and typesafe and the request
response pattern gave us a ton of
flexibility that would that we took
gleefully took advantage of and we were
having a good time until a few years
later a problem emerged and we couldn't
really sweep it under the rug and longer
historically code expressed with Mona
transformers is faster than that
expressed with an algebraic effect
system GHC loves monad transformers it's
able to compile them down to extremely
efficient code thanks to their fixed
interpretation algebraic effects don't
have a fixed interpretation and the
optimizer can pays the cost for that so
you can easily write a benchmark with
Oleg's a fish Oleg's original effect
library that shows it to be three orders
of magnitude slower than equivalent of
ntl code now benchmarks are benchmarks
which is to say lies most interesting
programs touch the network in some way
or they read from files or do other such
high latency behaviors and in those
cases that latency not what effect
system you're using under the hood is
going to dominate the execution time of
your program but semantics is different
the bulk of a given invocation of
semantics involves interpretation of
syntax trees there's no i/o there that's
ball necked entirely by how perform how
performant the monads and the
abstractions we're using to analyze
these trees are and these trees are big
it's not uncommon to find program texts
that when parsed yield millions of
syntax nodes and sometimes take up
multiple gigabytes of memory just in
their AST form alone and when your trees
are that big and the speed of your tree
operations are bounded by your monad
your magnetic abstractions efficiency
and your running this code on every
single push to github you're kind of in
trouble and so here we see again another
collision of values we valued speed and
the oleg derived effect implementations
didn't it seemed like we have to accept
the limitations that mvl imposes on
expressivity in the name of decent
performance and again this wouldn't have
been insurmountable but it would have
been a huge bummer I hate giving up the
ability to express myself in the
language of my domain and it seemed like
all hope was lost but it was not my dear
friend and co-worker Rob did not here we
are at ICF P this year I like this photo
a lot and we look so happy or I'll
realize that there was a solution to
this problem in the literature and the
only reason we weren't using this
solution was that nobody had sat down
and implemented it the papers he
consulted here they are were written by
the dynamic duo of Tom Shrivers and
Nicolas Wu whose output is just
staggering it's so good they're on
another level they described over us
over the series of papers a recipe for
an effect system that could compete with
MDL it took just three weeks before Rob
emerged with the first views version of
fused effects and since then it's
blossomed into something that I think is
pretty special
it's a full-featured effect system
providing most of the effects you need
to compose and day-to-day Haskel work
and it runs with speed comparable to MDL
we preserve the good parts of the MDL
system ecosystem particular its naming
choices so if you are familiar with
writing MD applications you can come to
fuse effects without being over overly
bewildered while we remove while
removing those historical limitations
and standing off some of the backwards
compatibility induced rough edges and
it's open source it's permissive 3
clause BSD license it's up on github
it's up on hackers you can go and start
using it now I do and so the question
that I'd like to get through in my time
remaining is how how did we and by we I
mean Robin and Nick and Tom pull this
off and to understand why this is we
have to take another step back or you
can go and look at this term again see
the algebraic that finish a car just so
happy about I said that effects are
represented with data types and that's
the same algebraic as in one of
Haskell's core features algebraic data
types we use these types to represent
effects and here's the type we use to
represent the state monad
for some state type Val there are two
operations one get and one put I've
color-coded both the arguments in the
surface index and in the underlying data
representation to see to show you that
the shape of these data structures is
determined by the shape of the surface
syntax that we want to use and in the
real world we write this with a few with
somewhat
fewer extra parentheses this is the
actual data that we the data type that
we use inside fewest effects to
represent the state moment the notion of
effects as data types gives rise to a
really pleasing notion formalism of a
DSL some program text written in a DSL
is a tree its branches represents
scoping and control flow and its leaves
represent individual effects so if we
represent effects as data type then a
tree that holds effects is code and this
gives a certain nice definition for
interpretation as well if a DSL is a
tree of effects then an interpreter for
that DSL is a function that rewrites
that tree into something simpler a
computation that can be kicked off
directly by GHC I like these little
emoji here with a ornamented Christmas
tree to the regular tree because it
draws a good analogy it's the process of
interpreting DSL is to kind of pluck the
fancy spanglish surface syntax from it
until we have something earthier more
regular that we can just feed into GHz
and get an answer out you can see this
visually here's a computation that
depends on three effects a mutable
context value by a reader logging by a
writer and error handling by a error
we've got a fourth one here that takes
care of pure operations the process of
interpreting this DSL is that of letting
a handler walk through a tree at each
stage of the tree a handler looks the
datum held there if it's the fact that
it recognises it translate that
translates that into a lower level
representation as we've walked the tree
with handlers we get something simpler
and simpler until finally we've got
something that depends on no effectual
operations at all at which point our
pure handler can walk through and just
execute the whole block of code and this
is a nice fit for Haskell as a language
because Haskell makes it very easy to
represent the traversal of tree-like
structures if you're into folds or
recursion schemes like the Haskell is
nearly an ideal language for doing
operations on trees in that manner the
problem is that historically this has
been an inefficient process
in contrast to the Moana transformer
approach where semantics are specified
ahead of time and translated directly to
a data structure you're using the
interfaces and algebra this algebraic
effects approach relies on a repeated
tree traversal and this increases in
cost both with the number of monads but
both in cost with the number of effects
we're using and handlers we have to use
and with the size of the trees and is
made even more problematic by the fact
that historically free monads have
provided the tree structure used by
effects libraries I don't have nearly
enough time to get into the details of
the free monad but the 10,000 foot view
is that they're the simplest monad
capable of embedding computations
binding them and introducing further
branching and divergent control flow and
because the free monad captures these
capabilities and nothing more and that
these capabilities are needed for every
effect
Oleg's breakthrough was that we can use
free monads to plus effect types to
represent code and represent dsls
but the problem historically the problem
without the breaks affects efficiency
stem not just from the fact that we have
to walk the tree multiple times but also
because the tree structure that free
monads provide is not very fast to do
and just really about anything and
building inspecting and folding them
requires a lot of in directions and
those in directions make it hard for GHC
to generate efficient in line code so a
lot of the immediate research on
extensible effects concentrated on
making free monads faster in terms of
traversal and construction there was
already some research on this back in
2002 Oleg took another swing at it with
what's called a freer monad and which is
like the free Mon head but cheaper
Camargue at all use template at Haskell
to generate faster calls and Sandy
McGuire's poly semi library goes even
faster and goes even further but there's
two ways to speed up a tree traversal
you can make the tree cheaper to
traverse or you can cut down on the
number of traversals required the core
idea of the paper Fusion for free is
that we don't have to walk the amount of
that walk the tree a linear amount of
times the long-standing tradition of
research indeed into how to optimize
repeated treat reversals somehow each
handler was able to coalesce into a
single unit we'd only have to walk this
tree once and that would pretty ideal
the name of the game here is to turn a
linear process into a constant time
process if our handlers fuse into a
single handler we can avoid the expense
of building up trees and intermediate
stages it's not always straightforward
to actually make these handlers fuse in
a way that GHC understands the details
are a little too fiddly to go into now
they're outlined at length in fusion for
free for our purposes it's of Isis it
spices to state that there exists a way
to tell GHC hey these functions
absolutely have to fuse into one item
and to understand why this works we have
to consider how data structures are
modified in Haskell because we're
working in a language without mutable
data structures we don't modify modify a
tree destructively as we iterated
instead each traversal is two logical
parts it's the part that consumes an
existing tree and the parts that
generates a new one we call the first
part of fold we've called the second
part a build with fusion a pipeline of
folds then builds and folds and builds
unfold can be turned into a single
traversal rather than folding with the
singler single handler at a time we
compose these handlers and fold only
once allowing us to skip the expense of
building a tree just to have it fold it
again and the performance of real-world
Haskell code very often depends on
fusion of data structures and our case
was no exception after switching from
our effect library without fusions one
that displayed this property I am
observed a factor of 250 speed ups and
needless to say that's pretty
extraordinary maybe the most
extraordinary speed approach seen in my
career and even more extraordinary than
that were the speed ups that have an
undefined speed-up because they never
even finished in the first place and
then they started terminating in a
couple of seconds it was kind of scary
actually I'd like to lay out what the
values I think the fused effects team
holds at least my take on them I think
expressiveness
is the big one fused effects exists
because ntl really prevented us from
expressing us naturally in the language
of our domain we want and we want fused
effects to be expressed be able to
express your problem domain as well
whatever it might be in a holistic and
natural way and performance as well we
share that with MTL an industry you can
take performance hit hits of two and
five and ten percent now a hundred
thousand percent we treat performance
problems as the bugs they are and we
also really value rigor effusive ex is
based as I mentioned on a long pedigree
of research and we're confident in its
foundations and we achieve its
performance in a rigorous way if there's
no template Haskell there's no rewrite
rules there's no compiler plugins just
reliance and a long-established property
of GHC as a system they're things we
downplay or don't value as much other
effect systems are more concise
libraries like Freer's are simpler poly
semi placed a really high value on
avoiding all boilerplate code and while
that's a normal goal and we don't like
boilerplate either if boilerplate and
performance are at odds in our case
performance is going to win every time
we've also not done a huge amount with
custom error messages other libraries
provide more descriptive diagnostics and
we'd like to we'd like to do that as
well we just haven't gotten around to it
and we also come with really nice things
a lot of powerful effects out of the box
I showed you this slide earlier and
here's the native concepts that if used
effects uses for each of these I of
these effects we also have things that a
lot of effects libraries don't our
non-determinism effect is much more
powerful than the simple non determinism
that the list monad provides four
features prologue style operations
so during logical operations you can
backtrack to find alternate ways of
fulfilling your goals and you can
specify the scope of this backtracking
with what are called cut and call
operations and because semantics uses
non-determinism really happily this was
super important to get right and
non-determinism is somewhat
underappreciated as far as other
libraries or other effects libraries go
but we spend a lot of time debugging
this and a lot of time getting a dabs
lace cream another really cool thing
that we come with straight out of the
box is resumable except
most exception systems let you abort
from a computation by signaling some
failure condition and then you can
handle that abort but with our resumable
exception effect we were able to jump
back into the computation that that from
which the original exception was thrown
in a type safe way this is not a feature
that appears in a lot of programming
languages I think Common Lisp is the
only one that boasts resumable
exceptions there called conditions
they're even and then they're considered
somewhat hazardous because the of
comments less slack of type safety but
here we lean on newer newer GHC features
to provide of resumable exceptions in a
type safe manner it's really cool we're
attempting to keep the core refused
effects pretty minimal but where we've
already started working on a number of
libraries to help and so I won't read
these out here but we the gist is were
committed to making fused effects be a
library with a rich ecosystem and
there's one last cool trick that I want
to discuss which is one of the great
contributions to literature is a paper
which I'll call what binds them together
and the inside of this paper is that we
restrict ourselves to modular effects
but then we can prove that Moneo
transformers and algebraic effects are
equally expressive that means there
exists a recipe for converting on effect
to an equally powerful monad transformer
and vice versa
so we've incorporated this insight into
the heart of used effects fused effects
uses mouna transformers to generate its
code so we get all of the research that
gee and effort that GHC has put in to
making monad transformers scream but
with the power of an algebraic effects
systems so I think it really occupies a
sweet spot in the design space at the
intersection of algebraic effects
systems and monad transformer libraries
so at the end of the day with handlers
that fuse and get compiled down to a
monad transformer code at runtime we've
got a library that's approximately as
fast as MDL has compatibility with this
ecosystem but it provides new levels of
expressiveness and flexibility and so
it's time for me to wrap up so I'll go
back to the question I posed originally
which is how do we build programs in
Haskell my decade-plus writing household
this is a methodology that's worked
for me identify my effects I represent
them as data I compose them as needed
into a DSL and then I compose handlers
with fused effects to execute that DSL
house was a language that gives you a
lot of flexibility there's no one way to
do it but in my decade-plus writing
house gold this is the methodology
that's worked best for me if this talk
has interested you I please encourage
you to go use it for fun for work to
tell me our robbed or yell at us on the
bug tracker about how you feel about it
and please file bugs when you fund and
that's really all I have I don't think I
have any time for questions but I'd love
to talk to you up up here if you if
you'd like to pick my greens so thank
you so much for coming out
[Applause]